show that the number attending the able
town show first exceeds 10 times the
number attending the bush Creek show in
the 25th year hmm okay so how are we
going to do this right what we're trying
to show is that is all join group a now
you're gonna be careful right because
what is a what is a a is that partial
sum isn't it it's the first year and the
second year and third year all the way
up to be a few right that's what I am is
is that what the question is asking
about the question is how do I know how
do I know that it's not really talking
about a sub M what clues in the question
do I have that tell me they're clearly
not talking about the toll they are
actually only talking about the 25th
year what clues does the question give
me so the first is the 10 times theme
yeah like that that magnitude okay um
are there any other clues that I have
yeah yeah okay look right it says the
number attending the show do you see it
doesn't say anything about the totals
over a number of years it's just this
conspicuous absence right we've kind of
been in that mode cuz part a kind of
thrust us in that direction but if you
read carefully puppy is nothing in the
language of the question that suggests
it's talking about turtles okay so
therefore I can't use this notation
because I've already defined it in
another way right so you need to find
out if you like maybe just use am like a
lowercase or something like that so this
is rather than the song this is for each
individual gear right this works out to
be a lot easier to calculate in fact
we've already calculated it how many
people went to this show this show in
the NPA
it's on the board p / x times what very
good it's right there you see that was
my last year okay so this is like that
recursive definition again I want Tia
then in turn up the whole thing ok
that's a sub n I can work out lower case
B sub n which is okay there you go and
because what they're asking is I want it
to be the first time at 25th year okay
it would seem pretty like standard I
just need to work out these two numbers
yeah do you agree with that and I'm
going to show that this is at least ten
times bigger than this would that be
okay ah so it's my bad start I should do
this okay but do you notice for instance
if this is true now I could do this too
okay and this will also exceed ten times
for Silas right but just construe that
doesn't mean it's the first time
actually buy this time has been
happening for decades right so what are
we going to add to that yeah I'd be like
that's exactly I came back to the
quickest way now so I'm going to work
out this and work out this I'm gonna
show it works then I'm going to work out
this and work out this and show it
doesn't okay there are other ways you
could do it but I think this is actually
the quickest way and you can go to
inequalities but ends up being logs of
lawns and it's it's a disastrous mess
okay so you're going to get a number for
your number here show their works no
mekia number here and show that it's
just shy like you're you're literally
like 10 or 15 people off I can now last
question have a look at how about a pop
see this one's quick enough that i'm
just going to skip over that and we're
going to do Part C it takes like one
line one line I should say it only takes
one line because you've done so many
lines already right read the question
what's it asking
what's the ratio of the total number see
there's that clue total total so now
we're talking about our big a and queen
bee the total number attending the
ableton show over these 25 years to the
total attorney at the other one right so
a ratio is just a fraction right what's
the fraction going to be total read that
read read it it says it's cumulative
because there's total over these 25
years over run on so what are we going
to say is our fraction that will give us
our ratio yeah it's going to be big a
for what I 25 that's the 20 50 / be 25
okay and this number is going to be
bigger right so you're just going to get
a whole number out of this right not on
my butt nice no big it's going to be
bigger than one it won't be like 1230
something like that it won't be a third
or a quarter it's going to be bigger
than one or are we going to crunch into
this well we have all the pieces already
know it okay where's a 25 there it is
100,000 1.05 to the 25 minus 1 and I
have to save a hundred thousand here but
it's 1-5 95 to the 25 okay so you've got
the Indian education there on your
calculator some want to conjure them for
us three significant feeds
get out your way
sorry
no 13.3 3.3 there's my first two
significant figures is there no i + 0 2
4 so I'm going to just go a 0 there's my
third significant figure and it's a
significant zero because it's not just
like 000 forever is actually a number
after this that's also see if we filled
up cutting it off so that's three
significant because